Another important consequence of having several machines share the same
medium is that two messages can't be sent at the same
time, if they tried the data on the line would likely
be corrected. We say that there is a collision when this
happens. These collisions can have an important role in the performance
of distributed systems where multiple machines, connected by a local network,
are used to solve a problem. So understanding how and why
these collisions occur is important for the study of operating systems.
We'll discuss three solutions to the collision problem. The
first is Carrier Sets Multiple Access with Collision Detection,
or CSMA/CD, which was used with early ethernet. When
a node sends a frame, it also measures the
signal on the wire. If it finds what it
sent, then great. If not, then it assumes another
node was trying to send at the same time,
causing a collision. Therefore, it sends a special jamming signal
that helps ensure that all other nodes detect the collision.
It then waits for an amount of time that is part
exponentially based on the number of recent collisions it has detected
but also random so that the nodes don't all just mirror
each other and keep sending messages at the same time. Another
solution to the collision problem is token ring or token bus.
Here, the nodes in the network are arranged in a ring,
either through physical connections or
logically. They then continually pass around
a token that is empty by default that determines whose
turn it is. If this node here wants to send a
message, he waits for the token, then sends out his message,
and once he's received an acknowledgement, he then continues to pass
the token on around. The next one wanting to send a
message will grab the token, send out his message, wait for
an acknowledgement, and then pass the token around some more. This
system is fair, and it does not fail under heavy loads,
but it suffers from more latency than the more
aggressive CSMA/CD. Where possible, both traditional ethernet and token ring
have been largely replaced by switched ethernet. A switch is
physically connected to the nodes like the hub, but instead
of broadcasting every frame that comes in like the hub
it looks at the destination MAC address and routs the
frames accordingly. The advantage is now that we have fewer
collisions. For instance, two pairs of nodes can communicate simultaneously
whereas this would have been impossible before. Naturally, a switch
will need a table mapping MAC addresses to the physical
port it should send the frame out to. One convenient
way to populate this table is with learning. Whenever a switch
sees a frame, it examines the MAC source and puts
that MAC address along with the port number in the table.
Then to figure out where to send it, it looks
in the table and if it finds the appropriate port, great.
If not, then it just broadcasts the ethernet frame to
all the nodes. Once we run out of ports, we
can begin to arrange switches in a hierarchy like so.
In our top level switch, MAC addresses for this subtree
will all map to port one. Those in this subtree
will map to port two. And those in this subtree
will map to port three. Lower down in this switch,
the MAC addresses for these machines will map to their ports.
And the MAC address for all these other machines in
the network would map to this switch's uplink, since that's the
path along which the frame would need to travel. Switches dramatically
increase the number of messages that can be sent over a
local network. In the simplest topology where all nodes are
connected to a single switch, it's almost as good as having
a dedicated link between each pair. The only way that server
one wouldn't be able to send to server 1 is because
server 2 itself is busy, never because the link is busy, and even when
server 2 is busy the switch can cue up frames to be delivered later.